hello everyone
today we will explain how to get rid of
too many dimensions
especially after in the last video we
have learned that
too many dimensions can be often
occurs so yes in a sense today we learn
how to lift curses
there are many methods for
dimensionality reduction
like pca ica bba
funny yay okay i i messed up
here again pca ica nmf
lda ida disney umap
autoencoders and so on
and all are awesome coming with their
own solutions and
tricks but today we will discuss the
basics by example of pca
which stands for principal component
analysis
in a nutshell pca uses some heuristics
to find the most important directions
in the data then it can discard the most
unimportant parts
in order to achieve the desired
dimensionality of the target space
if the data would be two-dimensional
we could even visualize it easily like
this
looking at the data clearly there are
more important dimensions than others
in this direction the spread is not that
big
and if we would clamp all points onto
one line
we would not lose that much information
we would lose a lot of information
if we would get rid of the other
dimension of the spread
because there the spread is much bigger
and helps a lot to differentiate the
points
so the main idea of the pca algorithm is
to keep the directions of the biggest
spread
and throw away the rest until we reach
the desired
number of dimensions d prime
but how to do that with mass of course
but first let's think about this
intuitively
what if we would approximate our data
with an ellipse
basically a two-dimensional gaussian and
find out the main axis of the
ellipse these axis which are called
principal components are
exactly the directions we are looking
for
we can keep the most important principal
components and throw away the other ones
but intuition does not compute stuff for
us
math does so let's see how we would do
this mathematically by setting up the
pca
algorithm first let's suppose we have
our data x which is a matrix with
rows containing all our data points the
columns contain the features of
these data points then we want to
centralize our data
meaning that the mean of all points
should be zero
how to do that by taking the data
and subtracting its mean done after this
simple transformation we are ready to go
on
we want to find the biggest spread or
variance of the data
because this is the informative part the
part most unpredictable of the data
for that we compute the scatter matrix
of the data
defined by this formula and remember we
have already subtracted the mean
this is the reason why the formula for
the scatter matrix
is not more complicated but what is this
thing the scatter matrix
we remember that our data x is composed
of
rows of the dimensional vectors
if we take one of these rows transpose
it and do the multiplication we get a d
by d matrix
and of course we sum this all over our
data samples
i why have we done this we wanted to
compute the main
axis of the ellipse well it turns out
that
the directions of the main axis are
actually the eigenvectors
of this scatter matrix and each
eigenvector has a so called eigenvalue
which captures the importance of the
eigenvectors so the magnitude of the
spread
so this is what we do we take the
scatter matrix compute eigenvalues and
eigenvectors
for big matrices we do it of course
in code like with this
in python now that we have eigenvectors
we can sort them by
eigenvalue to determine their importance
and we are ready
to reduce the dimension for this we
decide on how many dimensions we want to
reduce
say d prime then we take the prime
eigenvectors
and we put them into a matrix like this
the eigenvectors are d
dimensional since they live in the
original space
and what we want then is to compute the
new position
z in the new space of our data points
like
this meaning that we take out each data
point
x and multiply it with this matrix v
of eigenvectors so we have x
i one times the matrix which is a vector
multiplied with a d times d prime matrix
what comes out is a 1 by d prime
matrix which is a vector so vectors in
our new reduced
d prime dimensional space so because v
projects our points x from a higher
dimensional space into a lower
dimensional space d
prime we call v the projection matrix
what this projection matrix actually
does is it rotates the data
and maps it to a new space with lower
dimensionality
than the original one and that was it
and the best part is we only have to
understand the idea once because the
implementation of the algorithm
is already available in python with
scikit-learn
let's have a short look on how to use it
this is one of the official scikit-learn
examples where dimensionality reduction
with pca
is applied to the iris data set
containing different flowers with four
different features to differentiate
between them
like for example petal widths and links
but we humans cannot really visualize
the four dimensions
uh until we do not reduce them to at
least three
dimensions and this is luckily exactly
what this code does
while the code might look dense we will
now have a gentle introduction into it
because you really have to know
that pca relevant lines are very few
the first python lines are as always
importing specific packages
like numpy for multi-dimensional arrays
matplotlib piplot for plotting and of
course
sklearn for the machine learning part
a scalern is so kind to provide us also
with datasets
so we load the iris data and save it
into the variable iris
in machine learning it is a custom to
save the data into a variable called
x and the labels in y we initialize the
pca model by using the class from scikit
learn
as a parameter we specify the number of
principal components we want to keep
so the dimensionality of our target
space d
prime which is now 3. basically this is
the line where we specify
that our intention is to reduce from the
original dimensionality of 4
to 3. and the cool part about
scikit-learn
is that you can exchange this line with
many other dimensionality reduction
algorithms
but now with pca we fit the model to the
data x
and we do not use or need any labels y
since they are not of any use in the pca
algorithm
which is a blind signal separation
technique
with the fitted model to our data which
has internally done all complicated
things for us
like centralized the data computed the
scatter matrix
computed eigenvectors and sorted them
after the eigenvalues
formed the projection matrix with them
so now it is ready to be applied on the
data to compute the new representation
which is stored here again in x x is now
three dimensional and we are basically
done we can use the rest of the code to
make the 3d visualization that you see
here at the side
is it really that easy yes it is
now you have no excuse not to use
dimensionality reduction when needed
do not forget to like and subscribe okay
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you